j'ai sorti mon premier livre chez
Flammarion un recueil des nouvelles
érotiques j'ai été j'ai eu une grosse
promotion j'ai été invitée à l'émission
vol de nuit
c'était très gros émission littéraire
sur TF1 qui passait aux alentours de
23h30 c'est ça voilà exactement qui
tombe dans 3e entre la deuxième la
troisième partie de soirée oui donc
c'était pépédia qui présente vol de nuit
exactement voilà l'émission soit se
déroule correctement
après il y a un petit aparté après
l'émission comme ça où tout le monde
s'est réuni l'émission se tournait se
tourner dans les locaux de TF1
[Musique]
non je crois pas que c'était
vous voyez vous
et en fait voilà c'est un petit peu de
manière informelle comme ça après
l'émission une espèce de débrief général
et
[Musique]
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor ne m'a jamais
fasciné
donc je m'en fous un peu et
je vous demande si toi je m'en fous
total mais total
ça arrive voilà moi j'aurais dit pareil
moi je vous dis voilà et je vois mon
attaché de presse en l'occurrence donc
Patrick me parlait et pendant qu'il me
parlait il me lâchait pas la main en
même temps et je vois mon attaché de
presse qui est derrière lui au moment où
j'hésite et qui me fait les pouces bébé
comme ça
et donc je dis oui d'accord donc voilà
on prend rendez-vous pour que j'aille
assister au JT et par la suite après le
JT que nous échangions sur ma carrière
bien sûr voilà donc là c'est après votre
premier livre ça c'est en novembre 2003
et forcément voilà après warm up donc
vous y allez vous êtes invité à venir le
voir au JT de TF1 pour l'instant vous
sentiez aucun danger avant
non mais après je trouvais son intérêt
un petit peu
un petit peu un petit peu démesuré quoi
je suis pas
je suis pas gênant non plus quoi je veux
dire
Châteaubriand donc possible
[Musique]
il y avait eu énormément de promo les
gens on avait énormément parlé donc
alors vous vous admiriez pas plus que ça
à l'époque donc vraiment c'était pas
donc vous y allez quand même aux JT
vous y allez donc c'est vous y allez
tranquille vous allez tout seul oui j'y
vais toute seule
comme vous voulez que vous ayez elle
aurait pu venir avec vous non non elle
est pas venue et donc je vais par mes
propres moyens
j'arrive une assistante me fait monter
donc à l'étage où il y a le studio là on
installe
sous la caméra à côté du prompteur et
il se passe à peu près 20 minutes avant
la prise d'antenne ou des gens en fait
divers viennent me parler comme voilà le
staff autour et pour savoir où je mets
mes affaires et tout ça et à chaque fois
on veut dire on me nomme par un prénom
qui j'ai pas le mien donc ça peut être
Marie Julie Mélanie alors que en
l'occurrence justement un prénom qui est
cassé qui est pas très banal que
classique qu'on retient en général et je
me dis bon là ça fait toi un peu
beaucoup il y a dû avoir un défilé cette
semaine de fille
voilà je me trouve
et donc là je me dis
[Musique]
c'est bizarre quoi je suis pas très à
l'aise le JT commence Patrick arrive
vraiment
presque une minute avant la prise
d'antenne et le JT commence
donc et entre donc et entre chaque sujet
quand entre chaque
quand il fait ses lancements voilà il y
a des reportages oui voilà pour le
moment
donc il me fait un peu des choses assez
complices que le mot que tu veux que je
dise
voilà voilà des petits clins d'oeil
comme ça et moi je suis vraiment sous la
caméra entre
témoignage est incroyable parce que
Bénédicte c'est le premier témoignage
qu'on a au Bénédicte en fait elle s'en
fout totalement c'est ça qui me fait
rire et c'est pour ça que elle est pas
du tout facile à dire vous dites mais si
en fait c'est ça en fait elle est on a
eu des témoignages de jeunes filles
voilà de femmes voilà qui étaient voilà
qui disait qu'il était très fan voilà
donc bon elle c'est ça qui est drôle
c'est que tous les gestes et se dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'il veut lui en fait non
mais ça c'est c'est c'est assez drôle et
c'est c'est vraiment un autre type de
témoignage que c'est la première fois
qu'une présumée victime obligé de dire
présumé voilà et à cette distance avec
avec BDA avec la télévision avec voilà
donc vous vous avez écrit votre livre
vous avez fait votre truc et puis après
bon vous dites voilà c'est pas la
recherche de la gloire voilà de lancer
alors j'avais écrit mon livre je pensais
même pas le publier je veux dire c'est
j'ai ça a été une espèce de d'édition
Express
où j'ai eu tout d'un coup voilà
Géraldine pendant témoignage ou même
j'ai eu le paquet et ça m'est tombé
dessus moi je pensais pas du tout
publier ce livre et je me suis retrouvée
en l'espace de 6 mois dans un milieu qui
qui n'était pas celui dans lequel
j'évoluais alors vous allez nous
raconter ce qui se passait ce qui s'est
passé après Géraldine je sais que les
équipements dit que vous connaissiez
Bénédicte alors la même maison d'édition
Flammarion on avait comme éditeur
Frédéric Beigbeder et je connaissais
bien je connais c'est bien sûr Bénédicte
et je me souviens qu'effectivement quand
son premier roman est arrivé warm up
effectivement elle était prop dans
toutes les télés tu avais fardisson tu
avais absolument
éditeur mon éditeur et son éditeur et
vous vous on en parlera après vous avez
dit voilà que votre éditeur ne croyait
pas cette histoire voilà
bien sûr alors Bénédicte après le donc
après le journal se termine voilà
[Musique]
ferme la porte et tout d'un coup voilà
il est
comme si on était des vieux amis voilà
oui
[Musique]
mais faire un petit peu le tour du
propriétaire il me montre la formidable
vu qu'il a en haut de la tour TF1 sur
Paris
il me montre la bibliothèque avec des
photos on va dire un peu trop fait de
lui avec des gens importants des
présidents donc ça peut être Bill
Clinton il y a sera Arafat il s'attarde
pas mal sur même beaucoup sur une photo
de Solène ça suffit
il me propose de boire de l'alcool je ne
bois pas néanmoins lui se met en
consommer et
la discussion l'acide a son bureau se
lance un peu sur
voilà pourquoi j'écris
voilà des choses qu'elles sont mes
thèmes qu'est-ce que je lis bon somme
toute une discussion on va dire assez
classique qui commence à dévier à un
moment parce que donc quelques jours
avant en fait j'avais fait l'émission
donc tout le monde en parle d'Ardisson
ou tirer Ardisson avait
balancer sur le plateau en fait
mon petit ami de l'époque
donc à un moment tout de même
extrêmement gênant en lui posant des
questions
particulièrement déplacées qui avait
fait rire tout le plateau et Baffie et
tout le monde et ce qui avait fait qu'en
fait mon ami était parti
sans vouloir répondre parce que c'était
particulièrement déplacé Patrick me fait
référence à cet épisode et me demande en
fait comment j'ai arrangé le coup avec
mon copain si il est jaloux voilà il me
pose également donc là je me dis bon
me pose la question à savoir aussi
pourquoi je suis édité dans une grande
maison d'édition comme flammarion et en
l'occurrence si j'ai des contacts si et
sans sans voilà sans savoir si vous avez
quelqu'un en fait il me demande
également si j'ai couché avec mon
éditeur tout simplement voilà et là
c'est comment ça aide des questions
toi-même un peu bizarres et malgré tout
je réponds parce que je suis bien élevée
et
là voilà la discussion continue à en
fait à briller
quand il se mâle parlé de mon poids
alors oui c'est ça il vous parle de
votre poids il dit que il aimerait vous
aider à vous nourrir voilà qu'en fait
il est très sensible aux filles qui sont
d'une grande minceur voire d'une
maigreur en l'occurrence il me demande
si je suis anorexique
et quand l'occurrence bah les filles
anorexique sont souvent très fines très
sensibles et que il connaît
particulièrement bien le sujet pour
avoir été père d'une fille anorexique
qui était et donc
donc voilà en fait là je me dis ça ça va
plus trop et pendant tout ce moment en
fait où la discussion vraiment dévie
vrille Patrick parle debout en marchant
dans son bureau il tourne autour de son
bureau il tourne autour de ma chaise et
à un moment quand il est derrière moi me
saisit en fait comme ça avec une clé de
bras je bascule en arrière avec lui sur
le tapis et nous nous battons alors
c'est vrai que vous n'arrivez pas à
décrire la scène libération relater le
récit de votre agression sexuelle dit
depuis donc il tourne autour de vous et
alors qu'il est derrière elle la saisie
par la gorge en lui faisant une clé de
barre ce que nous avais dit elle bascule
il se battent par terre il remonte sa
jupe il l'embrasse et son haleine
épouvantable la révulse elle tente une
feinte non pas comme ça on vaut mieux
que ça prenons rendez-vous et elle
s'enfuit tandis qu'il se lève pour
prendre son calepin
en fait donc quand on était en train de
se battre au sol et qu'il mettait sa
main dans la culotte qui remontait ma
jupe et essayer de baisser mon collant
j'ai vraiment eu un moment où je me suis
dit pas moi pas moi je veux pas et
en fait j'ai voilà j'ai repoussé d'une
main son visage qui était donc qui
m'embrassait de force et je lui ai dit
Patrick j'ai mis nos dés j'ai dit
méritons mieux que ça de manière plus
jolie je me suis dit voilà essaye de
t'en sortir par la finte parce que de
toute façon il avait la force physique
pour lui il aura de toute façon c'est un
homme moi je pèse 40 kg voilà donc
c'était la fin
il s'est levait aussitôt et donc il a
voulu
attraper son carnet pour pour fixer un
rendez-vous et même moi je suis parti en
courant j'ai pris mes affaires je suis
parti en courant dans un couloir sans
lumière voilà en attendant l'ascenseur
en ayant peur qui me rattrape qu'est-ce
que vous vous dites après dans la dans
l'ascenseur quand vous retournez chez
vous sur le chemin du retour vous dites
quoi
sur le chemin du retour déjà attendu une
demi-heure un taxi parce qu'on est en
2003 il y avait pas de il y avait pas de
VTC donc là vous cogiter je vais partir
revienne j'ai parti revienne
voilà je suis sous le choc
je suis sous le choc je vous en parle à
quelqu'un tout de suite vous appelez
quelqu'un vous pas la personne
vous rentrez chez vous vous faites vous
en parlez à personne à l'époque je
vivais chez ma mère d'accord et je vous
avoue que
24 25 ans
on n'a pas envie de parler de ça avec sa
mère c'est ça on va pas dire donc là
vous vous êtes vous êtes chez vous vous
sentez forcément mal vous n'en parlez à
personne la nuit vous y pensez toute la
nuit vous dites je m'en souviens pas là
pour le coup ça a 19 ans je m'en
souviens pas je sais que je sais que
quelque chose de grave et d'anormal
s'est passé j'ai conscience d'être passé
à côté de quelque chose de de terrible
mais c'est vraiment voilà c'est diffus
alors
vous en parlez ensuite à Flammarion
notre éditeur donc vous en parlez à qui
chez Flammarion je me rends dans le
bureau de Frédéric Beigbeder
juste après pardon
je lui dis que je lui dis mais attends
l'autre jour donc je suis allé au JT de
PPDA il m'a littéralement sauté dessus
il est fou voilà je commence à raconter
mon histoire et Frédéric
rit de son de son rire tonitruant que
que Géraldine doit connaître quand il
quelque chose de rire comme ça
rien n'est grave voilà et
[Musique]
en fait je suis
je suis sidérée je suis sidérée de sa
réaction
où elle est là et
[Musique]
Frédéric en fait prend Michel
Houellebecq voilà à partir et lui dit ah
bah regarde Bénédicte voilà
c'est la nouvelle sur qui il aime
il se passe que PPDA essayait de sauter
Bénédicte Houellebecq aurait conclu rien
ne change alors voilà et en fait moi je
suis dans le bureau debout et je vois
c'est ces deux hommes qui ne voient pas
la gravité qui ne me défendent pas je ne
vois aucun couru je ne vois aucune
colère je ne vois personne qui me défend
donc je m'en vais
je suis descend vers mon attaché de
presse
qui
[Musique]
qui me dit tout simplement mais à quoi
tu t'attendais
tu as 25 ans et une jolie fille tu viens
d'écrire un livre PPDA est un passage
obligé
alors deux ans plus tard
vous recroiser PPDA dans un lobby
d'hôtel vous êtes avec un enfant
endormis sur vos genoux et là qu'est-ce
qui vous dit
alors il y a tout un
c'est voilà il y a tout un contexte en
fait donc je peux pas trop parler par
rapport à l'enquête ça se passe à
Londres je rends visite à une amie
pour l'inauguration d'un hôtel
un PDA se trouve là et il s'avère que il
est proche d'elle
et donc moi je voilà je
elle décide alors que je l'avais averti
à maintes reprises de qui était PPDA ils
avaient débuté une relation après me
voilà les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
néanmoins voilà elle décide de passer la
nuit avec lui et elle était là avec son
enfant et moi je me dis je lui dis que
je rentre à Chelsea à l'appart avec son
fils si elle veut rester avec Patrick
Poivre d'Arvor
et là aussi donc je me retrouve dans ce
lobby d'hôtel à travers square avec avec
un enfant de 9 ans qui s'endort il est
très tard et il est taxis n'arrivent pas
et c'est très long et tout d'un coup
vraiment derrière moi
derrière les plantes vertes il y a
j'entends la voix de Patrick Poivre
narvor qui a une boîte noire très
particulière qui me dit Bénédicte nous
pouvons reprendre nous en étions restés
et donc je sursaute l'enfance réveille
et il l'a fait fuir
en insultant
il y a des détails qui posent question
puisqu'on se demande si TF1 était au
courant ce soir vous ne révélez qu'il y
avait quand même une assistante qui vous
emmenait sur le plateau qui vous
emmenait à son bureau donc il n'était
pas seul et qui visiblement devait
assister tous les soirs à ce spectacle
donc il y avait un vrai mode opératoire
et l'autre chose qui ressort apparemment
au-delà du fait que les agressions
auraient lieu dans son bureau c'est
qu'il faisait miroiter à chaque fois des
opportunités professionnelles aussi en
tant que
ça part mais oui je pense que il m'a
pris pour une loi blanche alors
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la
justice alors
juste avant de rentrer en plateau
j'entendais que vous évoquiez le côté
serial et ce serait vraiment bien que la
justice le fasse pour la faire pppa
parce que nous sommes des dizaines et
des dizaines de femmes qui avons soit
porté plainte soit témoigner de manière
anonyme ou à découvert
qui souffront de ne pas être
suffisamment entendu qui souffront de de
sa morgue de son dédain voilà de son
mépris
envers nous
il continue à porter beau à se faire
inviter moi je
souffre
à chaque fois quand je le vois en une
par exemple je prends le train cet été
avec mon fils au relais Hachette il est
en couverture de voici à la plage je
souffre je suis invitée à un salon du
livre il est président d'honneur je
souffre je je me dis non ce n'est pas
possible donc
la prescription en France fait que les
faits sont trop vieux pour qu'il soit
jugé donc nous ce qu'on attend c'est un
procès c'est qu'il soit entendu c'est
qu'ils se tiennent devant le juge et que
la justice après façon travail mais il
faut aller jusqu'au procès
un tel comportement ce n'est pas un
délit ce n'est pas de la drague lourde
c'est un c'est un crime
Géraldine je suis très touché parce que
raconte effectivement Bénédicte et puis
moi je me repense moi jeune romancière
parce que vous étiez dans la même maison
d'édition mais maison d'édition invité
aussi pour vol de nuit avec PPDA je l'ai
raconté aussi ici maintes fois
effectivement je suis après l'émission
et jeune romancière donc moi c'est
encore il y a plus longtemps que toi et
effectivement moi il me poursuit à la
fin de l'émission et je l'ai raconté ici
entre les deux portes battantes je suis
donc toute seule avec lui et il me dit
vous me plaisez beaucoup j'adore votre
roman le même mode opératoire que tu
décris de manière très pressante il est
très pesant comme ça et puis je dis bah
écoutez tant mieux il faut qu'on se
revoit je dis bah non on se reverra pour
mon prochain livre et en fait je dégage
et je lui mets une sorte de râteau comme
ça et effectivement voilà je me dis que
par cette réponse là et par voilà mon ma
défense et ma force à ce moment là j'ai
peut-être aussi évité peut-être un drame
ou pas voilà donc je
c'est vrai que je me dis que ça se joue
aussi à peu de choses aussi de basculer
dans voilà dans un dans un dans un drame
intime qui est vraiment très touchant
merci Géraldine et surtout merci
Bénédicte d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci d'avoir trouvé la force de vous
exprimer en direct je pense que c'est
important je voulais
te ne pas être anonyme je pense que
derrière le mot viol il faut que chacun
réalise que sont des femmes qu'on est de
voilà qu'on essaie de chair qu'on
souffre toutes qu'on ait des mères qu'on
est des soeurs qu'on est des filles et
que il y a un bonhomme qui s'en est pris
à nous de manière sérieelle au même
endroit de la même manière et qu'on a
tout le même profil